so we're going to be going over some
video objects that we created and what
you can do with it in a language no they
go and you can play back just like audio
stream you can just play back without
seeing anything analysis processing
those would be you get in the frames and
what you can do with them
and then we are the underlined it's
package that were using is ffmpeg tools
yeah so we're doing going to do some
comparison as far as our functionality
againsts I mean our case but compared to
what I have so so there we go so here is
our nice new King objects so um so
basically that's a video that we get
from the web it's a simple craft I mean
simple query now feedbacks always nice
so we have one to check to see whether
that's video sure and we have the Q
function for its we can get some
information out of it where it's located
because right now we only pull out of
course there's no way we can fit that in
memory so it's a location for its
duration is frame rates size all the
architects and we also have different
kind of a review for them that's
actually we will lights keep back on
those who is what is it playing
so there are
like YouTube kind of the GUI interface
Voyles of course you cannot do anything
else other than causes stuck in this
kind of GUI then we also help oh there's
a static one that we actually open a
system player this is one of the thing
that we're trying to see how people like
them as I said in the previous talk we
support more video formats video codecs
than many players including the default
Mac layer which is QuickTime so some
things but this is one idea for having a
lightweight GUI that we have a static
thumbnail and then upon click you can
open the video in a default player as
one option I don't know maybe it
survives maybe not so what do we have
here oh there we go so we can have a
stream that plays with it here you can
most of them are static informations
like video tracks number of tracks
currently where you are on the track
device that you can output you so the
way to place those and you the way that
you manipulate those is through
properties like the property of the
streams so we have a lot of the property
most of them are static the only thing
that's different is the current frame
and the current positions so then you
can do dynamic on those guy and then of
course your video play as you display it
or
if you do a dynamic on their current
friend that you should you start again
[Music]
they move too far up there we go
my dynamic is taking over anyway you can
stop it pause it and then you can also
change the occurrence there's a property
that current tracks for audio or video
or subtitle so we can choose the
equivalent track that you want um what
else that's not here oh there we go so
then there goes the analysis part and
that's where she comes so yes we
introduced a video object there are a
couple of few functions that we
introduced as a first step for analyzing
and processing videos in this talk we
decided we'll just show a few examples
if you have been in other talks some of
them may sound redundant but these are
basically to give ideas of what's
possible now what's coming next
this is a very simple operation like
computing them in intensity and then
plotting it and same thing doing a
channel wise for all of the RGB channels
and all sorts of problems and this isn't
this is one example that I will run this
is a video doesn't have an oh it doesn't
have any audio it's a musician playing
guitar for the first eight seconds there
is one point of view then it changes to
this view it's smoothly moving but so
every frame is different from the frame
before it but then there are a couple of
jumps so there are three views that are
being captured in this video and this is
the last view if we look at them as
different scenes I can run this image
distance on every two frame moving on
with one frame on that video and I can
very clearly see the three peaks that
are telling me the times of each of
those scenes and we have a fine peak
function in the system that can
correctly find the location of those
then I
split the video on that times or do
something else
we have processing as well video apply
is one function that we have which gets
a function that gets an image in returns
an image and creates a video object so I
pre process most of these so that for
the ones that they take time we don't
wait for the processing but this is the
negated version of the image we could do
other things like for instance here I
have a video of two people interacting
you know one person sitting the other
one coming into the scene and I'm
running a little fine phases routine
highlighting currently we need to call
rasterize but we're going to support
graphics and automatically rasterize it
so as in many applications as you had
seen we can just highlight the faces
that are detected on the image and show
them in the video one thing i mentioned
in an earlier talk is the topic of
annotations we're going to be looking
into how we can store the detected data
from the video story then some kind of
an annotation structure not needing to
bake the result of highlighting into the
frames and writing it but instead
on-the-fly
highlight the video as well this other
one is the same thing we have a video of
a few people at a restaurant a person
serving them and a very typical thing
that objects are detected people cars
you know anything that that currently
our image cases which is feeding image
bounding boxes can detect and highlight
them on the fly whether you can do these
real-time on a video or no depends on
the speed of the operation obviously
another thing we have a street video
semantic segmentation for instance is
another one that you can run frame by
frame it doesn't need correspondence
between multiple frames but again this
is a result of a frame by frame
operation applied to an image to the
video
and goes on I'm using that musician
example now that I have functions like
video apply or video blot math okay so
now video block map I'm using to get the
scenes but then I decided I want some
kind of and highlighting on the either
splitting or highlighting on the video
so what I'm doing is that I'm converting
those times to frame numbers let me not
run all of that it may take time and
then I'm padding each frame number with
five frames back and forth just to get
bigger period of time and I'm doing a
very simple replace with red which is
that if statement if the index of that
frame matches one of these that I've
detected I'll replace that with a red
frame and I go on obviously when I was
prototyping this I thought okay this is
really some kind of a apply indexed kind
of a function that might be useful to
have or a function that takes time as
well as frames into account so if we
wait about eight seconds to get to that
scene change we should change red
highlighting popping up then this is the
second scene wait a couple of seconds
for this scene to finish another
highlighting signal and we'll get the
last scene similarly we can use the
import/export capabilities that Peter
talked about earlier let me kill this is
a prototype bill just to make sure this
is gonna stay sane to basically trim out
which is obviously should be I think a
video trim video split function but I'm
using that time to read all the video
frames in and create a new video that
only has that first scene in it
obviously if I had audio for this object
I could have just got that part of the
audio from the original video and then
export it into the video itself the last
example we are showing is an example
that we released with the version 12
example pages this is a key point base
stabilization we basically have a
that is unstable this stabilization
problem is a bit difficult because the
object that is the bubble bubble is
moving as well as the baseline which is
the ground for this particular example
we are focusing on the bottom which is
the ground finding all the key points
and stabilizing the frame by finding
corresponding points geometric transform
from one frame to another composing them
and then stabilizing the whole thing but
if I scroll all the way up one thing
that we obviously didn't highlight when
we released 12 is that we are relying on
import of file image list range of 80
which could be very large if you have a
larger video this one could fit into the
memory so fine but if it doesn't fit
into the memory well here I'm using
exactly the same video so it still fits
but I combined all of those operations
like find geometric transform on the
corresponding points and then compose
transformation of frame 2 to 3 with the
transformation of frames 1 & 2 and then
that come that complete transformation
is being applied to every frame using
image perspective transform so this
operation is done and on the video frame
frame by frame or two framing one frame
out at a time so it doesn't need a whole
lot of memory except to be able to fit
those two input frames and compute the
output and the same stabilization can be
done on a much larger video that's that
journey you want to take over the ffmpeg
bar alright so not all of these are
gonna be super super efficient because
the frames are coming in we are
evaluating functions like color and they
gave and so forth which is color
negatives fast but then the operation
might be a bit more sophisticated at
time consuming this is a very initial
way that we hooked up ffmpeg and will
have to think how we exactly end up
doing that
but a combination of these strings in a
list form and ffmpeg filter which is
negating and lut RGB I don't know what
that oh okay it's a negating basically
our G and B and then putting putting
them back together so if I run this to
show that this actually works as well as
the color negate version that I was
working before this is basically the
same negation but using ffmpeg filter
rather than bringing frames into
mathematical kernel and color negating
that the timings we have a couple of
them are going to be different this is
the ffmpeg timing is three seconds the
video FY color negate is slightly slower
we are thinking about ways of hooking up
to ffmpeg and calling that maybe
performance goals speed could be one
option may be a better syntax if a user
cares for just putting in the ffmpeg
filters there or maybe whenever we
figure out that the ffmpeg filter is
exactly identical to what we are doing
which should be the case in the case of
simple things like color negate I guess
we just could call that up do I run the
shake so this is addy shaking filter
that Chen you found in ffmpeg which we
are trying to run it's oh you wanted the
bubble right so that's why it took
longer the shake itself doesn't have
that or maybe does have any masking or I
don't know I don't know but this one is
trying to correspond all the key points
that it finds probably in the image and
since the bubble is moving it's not
doing exactly what you want so that
there is not going to be one to one
correspondence obviously between what
ffmpeg provides and what we provide a
few other examples of timings we compare
it for instance that V flip which is a
very cool flip to our image reflect
almost twice faster
edge detect I think the default ffmpeg
is not canny ours is bigger difference
their imagery size which might be very
very useful if we want to show or
provide a video GUI that is just showing
your thumbnail and so forth also a big
difference and so forth so anyways this
is this is our back-end we just put it
there to say that if you want to use it
it's there and we are definitely gonna
be utilizing it a very quick sneak sneak
peak to a few examples of what may be
possible let's not bore you with more
things thank you
happy Halloween
[Applause]